we listen to Jason
who comes from the Department of
statistical science of Duke University
okay thank you uh it's a pleasure to be
here I've learned so much from all of
you to be at this workshop and just all
these disciplines it's really amazing I
feel like I'm in like a language
immersion summer camp or something and
speaking of I'm going to be mostly
speaking in the language of Statistics
here so for the young ones in the
audience that's the old name for data
science and in particular I want to talk
about how we fit these epidemic models
the stochastic version uh to data and if
anything my goal here will be to kind of
motivate the types of challenges uh why
they are rich problems interesting
problems for mathematicians economists
and all sorts of people to uh to to work
on
so this introduction is going to be a
little redundant after so many wonderful
talks today but in many disciplines
whether we want to actually understand
how a disease spreads or something
similar like gossip opinions of one on
the network it's often desirable to have
good models that have some features that
I will talk about in particular I'm
going to be biased toward talking about
mechanistic models so sometimes we want
to be able to use some of the knowledge
we know about how that is spreading and
also by having a mechanistic model
sometimes the parameters we want to
learn about are interpretable because
they correspond to certain physical
mechanisms
an important thing that has come up a
lot throughout this Workshop is we would
like to hopefully account for some kind
of structure and or rates of context in
the population so we've seen a lot of
the classical models have this sort of
mass action type thing this well-mixing
homo homogeneity and we would like to
see how far we can get in doing
inference when we relax some of that
and again this is uh statistic so I'm
biased toward random mod stochastic
models in our case we want to allow for
Randomness and I will focus on the
continuous time setting in this case
because again they're very interpretable
they're kind of very general and things
can be quite elegant in that framework
so uh I want to talk about inference
we've seen a lot of great talks about
sort of I think a lot of mathematical
results whether they're for the
deterministic or the stochastic versions
they often relate to what I will call
forward behavior of the process so what
are the thresholds going forward the
final sizes these kinds of limits
limiting theorems but uh inference
statisticians are often concerned with
the inverse problem so not what kind of
data does a model generate but given
observational data how do we go
backwards and identify the most likely
parameters hopefully also with
corresponding estimates of the
uncertainty of our estimates
so again my my main goal because it's
such a diverse audience is to kind of
give a taste of the interesting and
beautiful challenges that arise in
considering this problem and also
understanding why it's hard even for the
simplest models and then I'll kind of
give a little proof of principle in uh
how we relax these assumptions in some
cases
okay
this has also come out multiple times
today but just as a refresher the sir
model which is often attributed to the
seminal work almost 100 Years Ago by
kermak and mckendrick is a process of
infection that kind of treats the
population by compartments based on
disease status so susceptible people
flow into the Infectious compartment and
eventually recover and so many people in
this audience know the karmac mckendrick
model often refers to this simple
diagram depicted here but in that paper
they actually do some things very
generally they write things in terms of
Freedom individual equations it's really
lovely and I encourage people to look at
the original paper but for some reason
when people say The Chronic mechanic
model they mostly colloquially refer to
this simple model where there's a fixed
parameter beta and a fixed parameter
gamma that refer to the rates of
transmission which will make a little
more clear in the next slide
uh and so infection and Recovery
uh even in the general case they
considered everything was deterministic
in this original treatment
and uh in particular the simple case we
can describe it by a system of ordinary
differential equations Odes uh where we
see that given an initial condition and
certain choices for those parameters you
will have fixed trajectories of course
and there are these nice smooth
continuous curves over time uh this is
going to be familiar it's related to the
lockable Terra Dynamics or predation
prey
um so this is a the simplest case of the
sir model and it's even though it's
deterministic I do want to emphasize
that it is there's a non-linear term
here because of the interaction between
susceptibles and infecteds and that's
going to give us some headaches when we
try to do statistics on this
okay
for a stochastic version of the model we
can write down things that basically
look the same as those differential
equations but interpret these as instead
instantaneous jump rates of a Markov
jump process or continuous time markup
chain so these instantaneous rates
rather than being derivatives of a
smooth function are now the
instantaneous rates of the probability
of these discrete events happening
whether the infection occurs which means
s population decreases by one at higher
population increases by One recovery
event where R increases by one I
decreases by one Etc and then form for
completeness we have this event rate of
nothing occurring
okay so there's a lot of work that has
been known in this audience on how one
can justify the deterministic limit
um using sort of the strong
approximation or Kurt's Theory and uh
I've recently learned that atien has
great work on this for more general
settings with the non-markovian setting
last year
um but in our case uh this is going to
evolve as a continuous time markup chain
and just I'm going to assume a closed
population for exposition here so let's
just track two of the populations and
the last one can be recovered by some
traction
written as as is this is assuming
implicitly already this random mixing uh
sort of mass action type assumption
however you want to call it in your
discipline everyone is kind of bumping
into each other in a homogeneous way at
a constant rate or for instance along a
complete graph okay that's how we get
this beta times s times I dynamic
okay and in the stochastic version of
course we no longer have necessarily
fixed trajectories if I fix beta and
gamma and I simulate from the model this
is just one realization and of course we
see it's a little bumpy because of the
randomness but I do want to say uh the
stochasticity also adds to the
interpretability in a lot of ways so
first of all we've talked a lot about
basic reproductive numbers
um in this model it's parametrized by
those uh by those mechanistic parameters
it's sort of beta divided by gamma and
then you might have to normalize
depending on the way you define the
model and when epidemiologists when
Public Health officials talk about this
quantity they say it's an average number
of secondary infections however you want
to say it but I think this notion of
average makes a lot more sense in a
stochastic model where things really are
occurring with a probability law right
so rather than some kind of time average
that's a little bit abstracted through
maybe a Next Generation eigenvalue and
so this is appealing and for instance of
course there are other terms that would
we would like to naturally have a
probabilistic interpretation like the
probability of a large outbreak or the
probability we Peak at this time rather
than having them fixed based on that
some some differential equations
now again that was in the well-mixed
case naturally one might be interested
in eventually relaxing that well-mixing
assumption and here's just a diagram
depicting this in a simple setting if
you have five individuals under the sir
we are implicitly assuming that the
contact structure is a complete graph
right anybody kind of can come in
contact with anyone in a particular an
infected individual can infect any
susceptible but in practice we might not
have a complete graph and in fact that
graph on the right might change over
time so we would like to incorporate
that and this is indeed motivated by a
lot of recent data we talk about contact
trace and things like that uh one of the
data sets we've analyzed that I'll talk
about in this talk just because there's
so many Network oriented people in the
audience is that we might have mobile
Health Data in this case it's an
experimental setting so it's not easy to
come by this kind of monitoring in the
US but in an experiment this was looking
at the spread of flu-like symptoms on a
college campus and so people were
equipped with Bluetooth apps that are
pinging when they're close enough and
stop pinging when they're far away so
that's going to inform us of who is
close enough to be counted as a contact
over time and we can observe how this
contact changes and in our data set we
see that there's a pretty low Network
density and of course it's changing so
it's certainly not a complete graph and
it's certainly not static yeah when you
don't observe this you might expect that
well this is probably happening
so in this talk I'll talk about one
approach sort of the first attempt of
ours where we try to model the Dynamics
here and sort of the interplay in
particular that contact Network should
impact the disease spread of course
because you can only spread through your
contacts but your disease status might
describe how you choose to interact so
even though we do not have an economic
framework we do want to have your sort
of formation of Edge and deletion of
edge rates to possibly depend on the
disease statuses of the vertices
and then again this is really focused on
statistics so you might actually think
that these models are pretty simple and
I agree but in particular we're going to
try to do everything so that we have
access to the likelihood function and so
that we can fit the model to observe
data and sort of have it have our
inference be exact under the model right
so if we believe the model we're getting
the right estimates on uncertainty
properties and again these models are of
course going to be mispecified but it's
important to know what the estimates are
under your model so you can isolate
where the error is coming from
questions
so you so you have you don't do it on
the complete graph anymore you have some
given Network do you assume you know the
network do you assume your evolution of
the
is it a random Network do you want to
just estimate the parameters the random
network is the network fixed before the
infection or does it evolve via the
infections these are these are all great
questions we'll get to them and there's
going to be many slides later but the
important thing is that we in this data
set are observing that Network
continuously okay and we still would
like to learn its parameters so we still
jointly model it with the epidemic
um and that that is something that in
future work we'd like to know what how
we can impute that Network or just model
it uh via some rules and but uh for now
we're going to observe that Network and
we're going to have missing data in the
disease summaries the network is totally
it's it's observed totally yeah but we
want to still describe we want to posit
that it was generated from a random
process which we'll see yes
great question
so the partial observations I'm hinting
at will be limited in this talk to the
disease statuses and not the network and
uh hopefully many of you can help us
deal with the network issue okay
but so before getting to the network
stuff I want to motivate again just kind
of really motivate the challenges so why
do I claim that the uh it's hard to do
inference under these models even these
simple ones where I can write down in
one slide and you can all understand so
um well we first of all there's a lot of
people who are doing approximation so
there must be something difficult about
it and some common approximations are to
use discretizations over time there's
something that's been mentioned a lot in
this workshop for early stages because
the susceptible population is not really
being depleted in a significant way we
can have a single type branching process
that's kind of a birth death growth of
the infections and then for large
populations we can use things like
diffusions you know St type approaches
there is let's play more local costs can
see at certain times the time series sir
of kosher main Ferguson and then even
under approximations I would say the
tools for inference tend to be
computationally intensive so in
particular most of them the majority of
them are simulation based and what I
mean is they're based on sort of
simulating virtual outbreaks and hoping
that they kind of match your your data
that's my Layman's explanation of that
this includes sequential Monte Carlo or
particle filtering as well as sequential
ABC which is a further approximation of
this and I don't have anything against
these methods I think they're very
powerful in general I also think it's
great how they're kind of plug and play
and many practitioners can use them but
from my limited experience they can be
sort of uh they work well when they do
and when they don't you might be stuck
right and so for a furthermore just
statistically you can see that sometimes
they suffer poor mixing uh degeneracy
when weights are kind of stuck and I've
just basically just non-trivial to
implement non-trivial to a pull-off
computational
at all of the homogeneous setting so the
question was is this even true of Sir so
I think it's really a computational
problem that it's it depends on your
data set so I can talk more about this
offline but it's not that it's hard to
simulate the process that's easy it's
like if you simulate the process and
your data you know your data is not
generated from Sir right so you're
trying to tweak the parameters and have
things pass through your observed data
but you might have to reject a lot of
things that don't or if you have
something that re-weighs those weights
might become degenerate and you can have
really contradict paradoxical things
like sometimes these methods might work
better when you have noisier data
because there's more sampling noise to
let your particle filter kind of carry
through the particles whereas if you
have finer data it actually gets stuck
more so I can talk more about that
offline it's a great question though
um and it's great to question what I'm
saying because like the simple Sr model
is simple so why is it hard and so even
for the recent Ebola outbreak you know a
lot of the World Health Organization
estimates are based on the terministic
things so instead we want to sort of
advocate a likelihood-based method for
the for the stochastic case okay
and you still might be skeptical because
okay the Esquire Fireball is actually a
really nice mathematical object so for
those of you who do statistics things
like the likelihood function should be
nice so let me give a little bit of
background
when we have a continuous time markup
chain it is sort of uh fundamentally
defined by this quantity called the
infinitesimal generator or rate Matrix
I'm going to denote that q and so uh in
a Markov chain you usually have a
transition probability Matrix which is
each step where does it go and they're
really probabilities here these are
instantaneous rates and in fact the sums
of the rows will sum to zero and what I
mean by instantaneous rates is that for
instance if you have two states in your
state space denoted X and Y the x-wife
entry of this Matrix tells you the rate
of the exponential waiting time moving
from X to Y so when I'm in state X the
rate of jumping out I can jump to any of
the other states so I'm summing over the
rates of the second argument and that's
my total leaving time right you can
think of it as a an exponential alarm
clock to move here a different one to
move here and then the minimum of those
the first state is what happens and of
course the minimum of a bunch of
exponentials is has a rate as their sum
of the rates
so the diagonal entries give that rate
of jumping out and the diagonal itself
is the negative so that the rows are
conserved to zero so it's a
non-explosive process and you can
imagine in the exponential the Markov
case the likelihood should be simple
because what happens is your chain is
choosing where to move based on
exponential waiting times and the
likelihood should be a contribution of
exponential densities basically this
very nice expression it's a member of
the exponential family has a really nice
it's easy to work with right so so far
with everything is still easy it should
be easy statistically
just a little simplification when I
collect those terms for a general
continuous time markup chain I can
Factor it so that what happens is that
the likelihood of a trajectory is the
product of all the transition rates
between the states I observe and the
dwell times so the other part of the
exponential uh distribution uh e to the
time I've spent in each state X so when
I take the log of that if I asked an
undergraduate in statistics to find the
maximum likely estimator right that's
likelihood based inference they could
differentiate that set it equal to zero
and just tell me on a homework problem
that you know the mle for each of these
rates is just based on these sufficient
statistics I count the number of
transitions of each type and divide by
the dwell time in that first state so
this and there's a theory of inference
for this there's Central limit theorems
and if you want to be Bayesian there's
also really nice posterior conjugate
relationships you can put gamma priors
on the rows of this and have really
simple updates okay so inference is
quite nice for this class of models and
we're still in the Markov setting
so what do I mean when the inverse
problem is hard under the simple models
because the sir model I haven't put it
into this notation but it's it's a case
of this
so it's because of missing data right if
we are observing for instance incidents
we're only observing one compartment and
also if we're observing things like
let's say daily or weekly we're
observing summaries of the possible
realizations and the sort of complete
data should cross through our
observations what do I mean by that this
is a terrible picture I'm sorry but like
let's say the why our observed data of
something like infections and uh we have
uh every week so why not y1 is week one
week two week three so the dotted line
passes through those and the step
function is one continuous time markup
chain trajectory right so you can go up
and down up and down as long as it
passes through my observed data but then
the solid line is another instance with
you know a different probability a
different likelihood that also is
consistent with my observed data so if I
only have partial data I need to base my
inference on the likelihood of my
observations and that should somehow be
related to summing over and accounting
for the probabilities of all the paths
that are consistent with what I observed
right so that problem is simply called
like marginalization right or
integrating over the latent space but it
can be hard for models like this okay
this is too much notation but what I
mean to say is when you have the
observed data instead of having that
nice form where you have exponential
waiting times between each exact event
that happens you don't observe those
events you only observe uh you know
these these things at an observation
schedule and now what you need is the
probability of going between states over
some observation time right and in full
generality that time we'd likely be able
to have these transition probabilities
for any finite time this is the
transient behavior of that process which
is
of time points
uh what is the situation so the question
was what is the situation about what You
observe I think here let me try to
answer your question so you know if you
have the continuous time process like
there's a million people there's going
to be tons of infections and recoveries
all the time and that defines the nice
likelihood the complete data likelihood
gives me access to these terms If
instead I have reports of
total new infections every week right
incidence data then I'm in this setting
and I would like those times to write
down these things and do this pen and
paper calculation but instead I need to
have multiple bold X's there's
infinitely many of them I need to
marginalize over right okay
great question and so
you can do this in general for a
continuous time markout pins in theory
like the the way you relate the
instantaneous rates to these
probabilities in finite time is there's
a beautiful relationship based on the
Matrix exponential but we can't really
compute this in practice for epidemic
models and other large population
processes okay because it's it's cubic
in the size of the state space and this
is not just the size of your population
it's like The Triplets of s i and r over
that population that's something we
don't want to work with
so I know there's going to be a long
intro because I want to motivate sort of
the whole area
okay so um we've taken some approaches
for similar processes these are just
teasers so these next four slides they
look the most technical but they're the
ones you have to you can zone out the
most
so uh some of you might know there was a
great comment from Greg last time about
how you know a lot of times these
differential equations can actually
serve as Master equations for the
stochastic processes and in particular
that actually holds for the generating
functions of such processes in cases
such as branching processes as many of
you are familiar with there's a lot of
beautiful mathematics because there's so
much structure there so in the past when
I've worked with branching processes
even multi-type ones you can define a
generating function which anytime you do
this in probability you kind of pull it
out as a sort of a contrived tool right
you define this object and the whole
point of this object is the coefficients
or probabilities you care about and the
game to play is can I characterize this
whole object and then can I pull out
those coefficients so just the usual
definition of a branching of a
generating function it turns out that
this satisfies a bunch of differential
equations defined by those for backward
or Master equations so we have taken
approaches where we solve those
equations maybe numerically maybe in
closed form and then try to pull out
these probabilities and even though you
don't want to numerically solve Odes in
a numerically differentiate like a
thousand times you can use you know
Fourier transforms to do this super fast
and get them all out at the same time so
kind of neat just wanted to point that
in case it's related to your work but
this also doesn't work well for
non-linear processes okay so branching
processes things like that are rate
linear that gives us a lot of the
structure we use here
for nonlinear processes it's much harder
right and we have that in sir we have
this interaction term it really like
ruins our lives and um there is some
recent work we had that did overcome
this in the simplest case of the sir
right so we're still on the simple test
the SR I haven't talked about the
network
um and I also want to point out again a
plug for kermak and mckendrick in case
they're listening in the 1927 paper
they're already giving a lot of uh
intuition on how important the sort of
relations in the LaPlace domain are even
in the deterministic case and here
instead of doing the sort of Fourier
series trick it turns out we can study
the transition probabilities of the
process in the LaPlace domain and derive
a recursion that has a continued
fraction representation so if you've
studied birth death processes Carlin and
McGregor knew this about half a century
ago for birth death processes even
general ones without linear rates and
the difference between us and Them is I
have a MacBook Pro so I can actually
sometimes do things numerically with
these representations okay so again this
is just a teaser I'm going through the
details here kind of quickly
but the nice thing about exploiting
these relationships is this was you know
it was actually considered a very
challenging problem to ever work with
that marginal likely push so
seeing that
so so I have seen that in certain cases
where you have exchangeability for your
processes and then it sort of becomes
easier but here you don't have some
exchangeability so why does this work
yeah it's not easy but um it kind of
it's there's a nice trick to work with
these sort of inter increments and then
they decouple to some extent but then
there's still a sort of dynamic way that
they build upon each other it's it's
really intricate in fact and the part of
the motivation for the rest of this talk
this is still the intro is that um these
are delicate indeed and so if I want to
do anything like remove the complete
graph assumption well I'm not smart
enough to do it maybe some people in the
audience can't do it but it is very
delicate yeah
it's a great question and I haven't
thought as deeply about exchangeability
as I'd like but I have a note on that at
the very end of this talk too
so we can do something numerical with
this we can use a bit and word widths of
techniques to do the numerical inversion
and we can actually compute those
likelihoods uh for the marginal data and
and try to do something numerical it's
just it doesn't it's slow and it's a
little bit delicate as you can imagine
for the simplest case of the sir which
is already very difficult so this is
this is work with uh the first author is
LAM o and this is with Forest Crawford
who did related work on birth death
processes and Mark sushard
okay so finally let's move past this
having shown you sort of the nightmares
one can encounter even though they're
fun nightmares even working with the
simple case when you try to reconstruct
your impute or marginalizer for that
process okay so I claim that it's not
easy to do these for more complex models
when we want to drop the complete graph
we want to maybe drop the markovian
Assumption which epidemiologists really
want to do and when we want to put in
more individual level heterogeneity
having rates with covariates maybe
further like how you know now at this
Workshop putting in economic incentives
putting in environmental terms but let's
try to see how far we can get still
using likelihood-based inference via an
alternative approach because when we
have hard integrals bayesians will tell
you well sometimes we can evaluate hard
integrals with markup chain Monte Carlo
right so the idea is can I replace a
direct integration with sampling and
even though there's going to be some
conservation of difficulty maybe I can
sample from something that'll that'll
make my life a little easier
okay so this was kind of quick any
questions before we go on for the next
part of this talk
so the idea here how do we what is the
core idea or the high level idea of
changing this difficult marginalization
integration to a sampling problem right
so here's a sort of sloppy high level
notation and um now Z is the complete
data with all the infection and Recovery
times and I only have partial data which
is now called X so when I want the
likelihood of that partial data like I
said you need to somehow incorporate you
need to marginalize over all the missing
data with respect to some measure over
the missing data so I'm just saying
there's some kind of integral over the
missing data and The observed data but
I've I've integrated over the missing
data somehow and that's the integral
I've claimed is so hard
so how can I change this to a sampling
problem so when you're a Bayesian and
you do something like Markov chain Monte
Carlo you try to use Bayes Rule and
you're learning about the parameters of
the process right so I'd like the
posterior distribution some Distribution
on Theta given X but when I flip that
around using Bayes rule this hard
likelihood in red appears so what if
instead I construct a expanded Markov
chain that's going to look at the
posterior distribution explore the whole
distribution of both the missing data
and the parameters jointly when I flip
that term around via Bayes rule the blue
likelihood the nice one that's tractable
the exponential family that is the one
that I use in my calculations okay
and so if I'm able to somehow do this
I'm going to have to explore a larger
space with my Markov chain but if I can
Target that joint posterior every
computation whether it's Metropolis
Hastings and I need to evaluate a ratio
with a likelihood or something else like
Gibbs those computations actually
simplify greatly so computationally it's
very quick on even a laptop
so the idea is to use a Markov chain to
look for the posterior distribution do a
random walk over the posterior
distribution biased so that it preserves
the uh the the data posterior on this
joint posterior between both the missing
data and the parameters of Interest
and let's say I am originally interested
in the parameters given my observed data
so what I really wanted originally was
Pi of theta given X and now I have Pi of
Z comma Theta given X
now marginalizing out the missing data
becomes uh trivial I have a bunch of
pairs data one Z1 Theta 2 Z2 if I just
ignore the Z's this is a correct sample
from the Theta posterior and you can
convince yourself of this based on
looking at the empirical distribution
and this is not my idea this is like a
general idea called Bayesian data
augmentation so maybe this is a new idea
for you it's a very nice one
there is a conservation of difficulty
because the marginalization converts to
somehow sampling over the missing data
and that's that's the name of the game
but we'll see that this perspective
might give us a little more uh more
flexibility to with the modeling
so now we can talk a little bit about
our attempt to incorporate a contact
Network that at least co-evolves with
the sir model
making use of this idea
so back to this figure let's say we have
five people and we have a non-complete
graph so we have an adjacency Matrix
that can represent which edges are
currently present in this network and
then to allow this to be dynamic maybe
that Matrix a should itself be a process
where its entries should also change
over time so just the simplest way to do
this let's say this is also a Markov
process switching between one and zero
and then hopefully those rates of
contact and deletion will depend on
disease status that would be nice right
so that's that's like the minimum to
have this coupled with the network in
any way
okay so in particular uh with some rate
I'm going to call the rates Alpha for
connection it should depend on the
disease status of the nodes but with
some rate they will connect and also
depending on the disease status of the
nodes with some omega they will break
their link right so these will be part
of the model
and we see that at least they depend on
the disease status simultaneously of
course the sir process is happening over
this network and we would like it to be
just the generalization of the complete
graph case so it should have the same
Dynamics in the sense that over an
existing Edge an infectious individual
infects with rate beta right
the recovery Dynamics are actually
identical because that doesn't really
pertain to the network
so at the individual level and we've
also had some remarks on you can sort of
think about asian-based or individual
based interpretations and you can then
lump them together into a population
level so at the individual level each
individual has certain neighbors and
they can pass on an infection with rate
beta along each Edge they recover
independently and then there's also sort
of just links between potential links
that are becoming added and deleted
right
as far as the subscripts on the link
rates we're assuming that recovered and
susceptibles are both sort of in a
healthy class just to reduce parameters
and then the infected and the sort of
healthy unhealthy links behave
differently
so when I aggregate this at the
population level what happens so the
overall infection rate or sort of uh
population level Hazard becomes a
product of course of that rate per Edge
and the total number of edges between
susceptible and infected so this is
actually not the best notation because
this is meant to see s i of T which is
different than S of T times I of T but
if you have a complete graph then the
number of Si links is s of T times I oft
okay so in some sense this is just a
simple generalization of the complete
data case and now of course recovery
sums up and we have the link activations
determinations also summing up but
needing the notation to count the number
of types of pairs so Jason are you
assuming that you're some kind of
configuration model here so so are these
links
randomly connecting
yes um so in in this way the same
probability or what's what's the yes
about the sort of um links here right
there's sort of ace at every uh set of
disease statuses there's just certain
types of links that can or can't exist
and they're happening kind of
independently I don't really know how to
call that but it certainly is not
um it doesn't have to do with choosing
Things based on degrees or anything like
that there's sort of edges in sets that
are maybe separated by type and then
everything happens independently within
those sets
foreign
it's not a stochastic block model as far
as I can
what is your configuration
uh so I think we are confused here
because some of things that is a
configuration model something stochastic
block model but it's what's your network
model I I'm actually terrible at all the
terminology that I've just learned but
okay I mean write the network on the
Whiteboard without terminology yes
um okay
so be and it's the other thing is
because I've seen a lot of those
presented in the case where sort of the
vertex set is not changing statuses but
in some sense if you have so let's say
the circles are um
are are healthy and then the X's are
unhealthy
okay so at every you know at this
instant in time because these are the
disease statuses then let's look at the
number of
um potential
healthy so so there's a certain type of
edge between
um healthy and not healthy right and so
here is a set of uh
of all of those
oh sorry this is not this is not one so
yeah there's another okay so there's
something maybe there's more and so some
of these are currently disconnected and
some of these are currently connected
okay because there's you know there's a
process for the adjacency majors and
then so how about this process has
nothing to do with the underlying
Network it has to do with your data
augmentation to simulate you still
inferring on the complete graph
I guess you can think of it as there's
an under yeah so the so this is
something that I don't know how to
clarify but in some sense our model
doesn't have any structure in terms of
social structure right this is why I say
it's not like a stochastic block model
there's a sort of uh there's a protect
the network is still complete but
there's our edges and being deleted and
added back in this in certain rates
so I don't know what I would call that
and what I'm trying to say here is if
the solid edges are currently there then
you know there's exponential waiting
times for when this will be deleted and
this will be deleted uh and and
similarly competing with when these will
be added and those times depend on the
current disease status of the nodes
right and then but these things are also
competing in the same jumbled up set of
exponential times and then the moment
this one for instance recovers then the
rate this Edge will be deleted changes
as well yeah and they're kind of getting
they're switching on and off but the set
of potential edges is complete and the
rates of when they're being added and
removed depend on the current disease
status so I can think of it some
behavior model if I know my friend is
sick I mean it drops the edge at some
probability you know I would randomly
add them and yes so I don't know the
name for it but exactly that but in some
sense you're giving me a little too much
credit because there's no friends here
right it's like you still have yes but
your behavior I currently have friend
can't leave these two notes you have an
edge so their friend yeah okay there's
some probability you drop that eyes are
just even if both are healthy but if
both are sick maybe if they have some
different rate if one is sequence heads
you still have a different rate yes
absolutely so you have some kind of
dynamic Network model which doesn't have
an underlying structure no underlying
structure exactly and that's important
that's something I'd like to audition
with it it looks I think it looks more
like a percolation mode it is very
similar to percolation but I'm always
I'm always a little hesitant to use the
exact words because there's adding and
the rates are changing but it's it's
kind of similar to percolation indeed
but it also sounds like you are assuming
that these are exponential times so so
this is a sterling Markov model
absolutely on some kind of augmented
space when you have the the edges now
that are being added or removed right
yeah so everything is marked out for now
yes
how to learn
good question so um the question was
what do you want to learn so I want to
learn the beta and gamma which will be
modulated by the fact that the network
is changing but one can also estimate
um the Network rates of course if you're
interested in the probabilities of
disconnecting when you're healthy versus
not you can learn something from that I
will say again because the network is
completely observed in our case it's a
little bit contrived to learn the
Network rates in the full uh full method
I will present because you could have
learned them separately just from the
network because it's fully observed okay
you could have like conditioned on that
but that's a more subtle point the thing
is epidemiologists might think of this
as making the model more realistic in
order to estimate beta and gamma
effectively but one can also you know
learn and interpret the link rates right
even
this is super confusing to me because
your network actually is coupled to the
state of the disease so I could actually
could not tell me at all who's infected
it's susceptible
because now I could sort of possibly
since the network is completely known I
can sort of see by the frequency at
which Edge is switch whether it's an
edge between susceptible so you get
partial information from just seeing the
network without even knowing that these
status
you do get partial information from
seeing the network yes I I didn't follow
your complete comments well it's not as
if you have an underlying fixed Network
which involves independent of the
disease self-devolved together and
therefore if I if you gave me no
information about the network only about
the disease only about the network I
could should still be able to possibly
infer parameters of the disease if you
give me sorry if you gave me what so
let's say your gamma would be zero yeah
okay then eventually everybody's
infected and then I see that all your
rates of the edges switching are those
between type I and I so I could actually
see that from your network data without
ever seeing the disease status of the
notes
I I'm sorry I'm not sure I totally
follow so let's talk about this a little
bit offline yeah I think it's I just I
need to parse the question sorry
yes um but I'm very interested to
discuss that what Christians say is that
for instance if you see that between two
vertices you have edges appearing or
disappearing you can say that this
vertices are I or s
we have we have observation of where the
edges are and are not and yeah I mean if
you so you can you know whether the
vertex vertices are iOS
you you for instance if an edge is
deleted you know exactly at this point
that one of the vertices should be I and
the other should be s that's why well
but no I mean they can the thing is they
can happen regardless right I mean these
edges can be deleted for healthy pairs
too and there's rates that differ
because you would think that you would
disconnect more if somebody's unhealthy
and so if you know those rates you can
back out the disease statuses If You
observe the network that's right but if
you don't know the rates then then you
yeah you observe the evolution of the
graph you can you can estimate the rates
yeah so you can so this is what I mean
by When You observe the complete Network
you could first estimate these rates and
conditions like that but right now I'm
trying to motivate just the joint model
right we do see it to some extent on how
the the processes are linked right and
in the complete data case inferences is
weird because you can do it in a
two-stage procedure there's a question
so so actually we don't get to observe
the exact time points of these sections
and recoveries you cannot estimate those
link uh rates because the link rates are
convoluted with the disease statuses of
individuals at those particular time
points so you still have to find ways to
impute or figure out those time points
of epidemic events before we can fully
learn those uh link rates of the network
I will say so fan is an author on this
she knows this well too I just I'm
having a hard time following sort of in
these hypothetical scenarios what I am
completely observing and what I'm not so
I I kind of agree if you knew all the
disease statuses and then you observe
the complete Network you can kind of
split things up and back other things
out but let's let's go on a little bit
and hopefully when I get to the data
setting that might make it a little more
clear yeah
so yeah the point is these these
processes are kind of they're all
happening in one markup process like
Greg asked and um it's markovian for now
but that will allow us to write down the
sort of in principle simple likelihood
of a continuous time markup chain okay
so there's a lot of notation again don't
get fixated on irritation just trust
that this is in the same form of the
nice likelihood at the beginning which
is a product of sort of nice exponential
terms to the number of times events
occurred and then a dwell time this is
written as an integral we've seen hard
integrals in many talks but in the
markup case this integral splits up to a
bunch of very simple sums okay so the
point is this is indeed a nice
expression that we can evaluate very
quickly when we use this within an
iterative algorithm such as mcmc sampler
um again I don't exactly know how to
call this even but I will say like a lot
of others similar models they're such as
like preventative wiring and things like
that I would say their properties are a
little more dependent on the degrees of
vertices as the as the network evolves
and there are advantages to that because
when you want to preserve things like
total degree you can do analysis on the
thresholds of these models
probabilistically our aim is like having
having things kind of being independent
not having structure will allow us to
write down a likelihood like this okay
so it leads it leads to being able to
write down the complete data likelihood
of of the Markov process which is nice
so we would hopefully like to leverage
this even though we're not observing
everything we are observing the whole
network but we're not observing
everything and again the mles and the
conjugate relationships like I said also
go through you don't need to worry about
the form the point is these are closed
forms that you can Implement and are in
like basically one line each
when you have those we can sort of
validate the model uh you know if you
simulate the complete data and observe
the complete data you can see the sort
of an empirical consistency As You
observe more events of those estimates
kind of just validating the form of that
likelihood and the derivation of this
model
okay we're just gonna partially observed
case here's another plot of the same
phenomenon if I have things like
incidence data I have the number of new
infections if I see four infections in a
week you know my trajectory could look
like that or it could look like this and
it depends on the number of recoveries
depends on the initial size and we don't
know all those things in our case I'm
going to focus on uh the setting where
we don't know the recovery time it's
kind of like this is trying to show and
of course by not knowing the recovery
times we don't even know the number of
recoveries per observation interval
so that that's the nature of the data
set that we're motivated by in this case
we have weekly data and over each week
we have these health status reports that
will for instance tell us about the
number of new recoveries summarized over
the week but we don't have those event
times that give us access to the nice
likelihood and so um again because of
the Bluetooth app we're saying that we
do know the times of social creation uh
link creation and deletion okay but we
we're not observing all the disease
statuses of those of those people which
will depend on the latent variables here
right because if certain number of
recoveries happen in this week your ins
population depends on that
so that that kind of we don't actually
know that disease statuses all the times
even though we observe what links are
between people if that if that helps
again I didn't follow exactly what was
on your question but I hope this helps
so the observed data is basically
missing the recoveries in this case and
at the very end of the talk I'll talk a
little bit about um
missing infection times as well
so how does data augmented mcmc look uh
you know I've mentioned that we're
trying to somehow introduce the latent
variables for the missing data and
explore both of them and mark up J Monte
Carlo in this case we do this kind of
alternating scheme where we first
propose either the values of the missing
data and accept reject or we can sample
them directly if we can get our hands on
the conditional distribution and then
conditional on the complete data we have
access to that nice likelihood and we
can do things like Gibb sampling in our
case which just means we have the closed
form distribution for the parameters on
how to update pump okay
I realize if you don't know markete
Monte Carlo I'm assuming a lot here but
uh I'm happy to talk more at Lancaster
after after the presentation
so as you might guess Step One is the
hard part right we're data augmenting uh
we're kind of proposing things and we
need this to respect the observed data
so like the figure I've showed you you
might think that's hard it was hard to
integrate over those and it's it's
notoriously difficult also sometimes for
large processes to do conditional
simulation so that is have a realization
from the model but also have it fixed to
pass through your observations and in
particular that's further Complicated by
the fact that well we observe the
contact Network which is great but that
imposes further constraints because even
though these edges are kind of Behaving
independently they don't know about
structure you know if you particularly
let this person recover and then that's
this person's only neighbor and this
person needs to get infected later sorry
if this person's infectious and this
person needs to get infected later we
can't let this person recover at a
certain time right so the contact number
is constraining us even more
but that structure can also help the
Markov chain mix which is a subtle note
we can talk about offline
so to not go into too many details a fan
who's in the audience the first author
of this paper was able to do this really
impressive work that not only proposes
the missing data conditional on that uh
that Dynamic Network at each step for
the amputation because you know you can
propose things you can have an algorithm
that you know moves things around
whenever it violates something but but
propose it in a way that is preserving
those probabilities in particular this
is what we call a Gib step in statistics
so it's drawing from the exact
conditional distribution so when we
propose the Z's here we also know that
that probability is preserved in our
Markov chain so we don't need to work
with with anything extra there or reject
uh steps and so this is you're not going
to understand this figure just from this
slide but the idea is exactly what I
said it's checking that we're not
letting somebody recover in a way that
violates somebody else who needs that
neighbor to be infected Etc it's
avoiding all those things but also
somehow doing it in a way that preserves
the conditional probabilities
foreign
so essentially this data augmented step
you say you essentially do rejection
sampling right so it's not rejection
sample because that's what I'm confused
about because if you have continuous
time you would have to have continuously
many rejections well no so I mean let's
say you have a week you can propose a
set of times somehow and then
um if those are in violation of
something you might have to move some
things around right and then maybe when
you move some things around to avoid
having to reject it you would think that
might change you know now it's a
different sample and you might violate
yes so don't you get biases from that
yeah well this was done in a careful way
where you can show that this is actually
the way that this is done is a
conditional drum so that's the cool part
yeah so you you it's done in a way
that's not biased because naively doing
it like maybe proposing things uniformly
and then just checking that they accept
like that they don't violate is not a
conditioned drive right so you can't do
this naively exactly so there's a lot of
technical work in here but it's pretty
cool
yes
so I'm still trying
to sort of parse through this so so your
data is what exactly you have the count
of of individuals of different types and
you also have this partial Network right
the different time points think about it
think about it as the complete
continuous Time network we're kind of
assuming we have that which is right so
so you have all the time instances when
the network connections are created
those were kind of assuming we know
those event times but we don't know for
instance the recovery event times so
when we propose those it changes the you
know unknown disease statuses of nodes
the total number of new recoveries
yeah that's what I mean that's why we
have to kind of impute like like when we
say we have let's say five recoveries we
gotta put them somewhere and we also
have to make sure that they don't
violate you know they don't need to
someone so you every Friday you know how
many people are susceptible oh sorry I
think we do know who's rich public
Society you know who is who so for each
note you know Friday evening and just
continuous technology
foreign
so I think that you know for every note
the infection State on Friday evening
and you know the whole week continuously
the network state from every Edge
exactly it's strange
it is I mean this is not something you
would expect an observational data this
is an experiment with a bluetooth app
it's very strange yes agreed
um so it was nice because it's a way to
validate you know this model building
methodology and I would love to you know
we will talk about this at the end a
little bit because I hope that will be a
little more open to solicit ideas don't
worry about any of these equations it's
just again once I have that hard step
this step is just one line in R for each
parameter it gives sampling uh based on
a conjugated relationship excuse me can
you go once like that so what what is uh
possibly infected individuals if you
know whether they're infected or not
it's because you don't know if they have
recovered is that true yes exactly so
they're they're in the middle of the
interval because like you need to know
who was possibly infected to respect
future infections that need to occur but
depending on where you put the
recoveries they may or may not be
overcome good so this is something I
tend not to like to talk about live
because it is the technical step but it
can be done and that's what's
interesting it can be done right
so I'm going to skip over this over for
time because it's just about the real
data results so we were able to fit this
data set I actually didn't even talk
about the fact that we have an external
force of infection too because this
study was on about 600 students but only
a subset of them had the Bluetooth app
so there's sort of another node outside
that's kind of continuously have this
immigration rate of infection so
um I don't want to talk about it too
much but uh the contact information is
uh telling us that it's low Network
density it's obviously changing but very
much far from a complete graph at all
times and then so when we analyze this
we were able to jointly infer the
parameters and have you know uncertainty
quantification under the exact model
which is hard to come by and so you're
not going to get much of looking at this
table but they did check out with what
we expected and what the epidemiologist
which is like the internal force of
infection was large uh you know some of
these parameters almost look like
different orders of magnitude because
there are short contacts which reflects
that low Network density and so this is
just to say we were able to fit this
data set under this sort of exact
approach
um I want to talk about a couple other
things in my last few minutes so let's
just discuss this initial attempt first
we do have a generative model that at
least has some kind of interplay between
the epidemic and network process yeah as
you see this is a this is a naive
Network model but is able to capture
that codependence which is nice it is
fully stochastic again this is still
markovian and we're able to really do
like the advanced inference so this is
that's new in many respects
a lot of discussions already touched on
this because a lot of bright people in
the audience right so it is not natural
in observational data to completely
observe a contact Network and so instead
the other thing is not everything always
has to be stochastic I will even admit
that so if you have really good
deterministic rule-based for instance
models for the network you have an
initial Network and you know you say
people will start interacting again
after a certain time or you have a
policy that mandates that then that can
you know fill in for the unobserved
network data when you don't observe it
but still have that be part of the model
I would love to combine this with you
know for instance even beyond that but
like an actual rational economic
framework probably myopic decision
making to make it trackable and um this
has been touched on too when we were
talking about what this model is when
you have a certain set of disease
statuses the edges are happening based
on your friends as Christian put it but
those friends are not based on operatory
friendship groups or anything like that
and we do wonder you know per class per
like healthy healthy infectious
infection just for healthy infectious
there's different rates and within that
class they're kind of independent like
Greg was asking but can we relax
independent for something else like
exchangeability or something I haven't
thought deeply about that but maybe some
um some experts in the audience can
think about what can be relaxed in a way
that still maintains tractability
and then uh just a little bit of teasers
to get at the end
at the harder missing data settings such
as when infection times are also not
known so we don't know any of the
infection or recovery times so far this
work is without the network but the way
that we've been doing this is actually
allows General non-explanation any
non-exponential recovery distributions
um in this particular way of data
augmentation and just as a teaser on
kind of the flavor of this this approach
we're using a branching process but not
the usual way we talk about branching
process approximations that's a
univariate type here this is actually
maybe related to something Greg
mentioned in the morning talk we only
want to approximate the rate of the
process but we want to let everything
still be accounting process still be
stochastic overreach interval and
overreach observation interval the only
thing we'll do is within the rate we're
going to let
s so usually s and I are changing right
of course that's the overall infection
rate and we're just going to decouple it
so that s is changing
but I is uh not changing within the rate
okay so what does this mean when you
have S go to i s is usually you know
it's it's depleting so in this case
because we've linearized the rate it's a
linear death process flowing into the
second compartment which is now a
immigration with a constant rate over
that interval death process and so this
becomes very tractable but it resembles
the sir rates very closely and not only
that we're not going to use this as an
approximation to the SR model per se for
our inference we're going to use this
very faithful approximation as a
proposal density and when we generate
times from this process there's a very
nice property that lets us kind of do it
very quickly again with like one line
for the infections of one line for the
removals because they're decoupled from
a non-linearity essentially what this
makes use of I've mentioned conditional
simulation can be hard for these
processes but if you have a poisson
process and you know that K events
occurred you know that those event times
are independent are uniform the order
statistics of those event times are
uniform for these processes there's a
similar transformation that makes use of
a similar property so there's truncated
exponentials instead but they have
closed forms and so this lets us kind of
put down the complete epidemic very very
efficiently but we can um this is just
to show you like if I have like six
weeks of data and I observe it in 5 10
and 50 total observations as I observe
more frequently and reset this branching
process approximation it looks almost
identical to the sir on this on this
particular example and because it's very
faithful it allows me to do proposals In
classical mcmc and make big steps in the
latent space and mix very efficiently
this is based on you know this work uh
20 years ago that does something within
this same primitive but is they're
moving things one at a time and there's
a reverse jump step and that it
basically becomes intractable for
anything other than moderately sized
outbreaks but we're able to run this on
really large data sets real data sets
simulated data sets on a single laptop
and get tons of samples in a couple
minutes with reasonable effective sample
size bayesians can look at this spot and
tell me it's not perfect but it's pretty
darn good for these applications
so this is another teaser not really the
focus of this talk but hopefully I've
convinced you to some extent that it is
worth revisiting fully stochastic models
even when we're interested in fitting
data right and there's a lot of
advantages when we can do so the model
parameters are interpretable and also
our estimates come with uncertainty
quantification and as we continue to
relax assumptions right because these
are still naive models we'll eventually
build to more reliable forecasting where
we know what we are getting out of the
models given that the models are good
the markup chain framework is extensible
in a lot of ways this recent stuff I
showed you again we can relax the markup
assumption on that work but there's tons
of open directions a lot of the
expertise in this audience can help and
in particular a lot of the things I've
surveyed at the beginning this is
complementary to those approaches right
I don't have any beef against those
approaches so it would be really
interesting to combine them with
instance for within sequential Monte
Carlo we're looking at a model that
transitions to the differential equation
stage after uh some some appropriate
amount of of the exact model propagates
Etc
so I just do want to thank at least the
student collaborators here a fan is in
the audience and she's a postdoc with
Mark scootrad right now she did the
excellent work on the network case and
is also on the job market uh Raphael is
a current PhD student at Duke statistics
uh doing the most recent data
augmentation work based on the bivariate
branching process and Jenny is an
undergraduate is doing excellent work on
change Point detection when beta is also
a piecewise constant so you get to let
it be heterogeneous over time but also
simultaneously estimate sort of the
model complexity of that rate while
having it parameterized by Sr Dynamics
and she will be applying the PHD program
so you'll have to fight over her so
here's uh some of the papers I've
mentioned of our groups um and otherwise
thank you for your time
do you do you have questions yes
I am a bit surprised that you don't
renormalize s by n
because I mean you expect the number of
infections per unit time to be
proportional to the number of infectious
individuals but not to lose the number
of susceptible individuals
and why okay okay but why is it
important because uh when you uh in one
of the last slides when you uh
yes this one
why don't I mean if you would divide s
by n then what changes more slowly is s
divided by n rather than I
so therefore uh why not uh keep s
divided by n constant I mean on the time
on this time interval and have the I
changing you see what I mean
uh uh kind of I mean my initial reaction
before you said let okay so first of all
yes you can do this you I think you can
decide which one you want fixed yes
because you linearize either the S
equations the I equation exactly
um and I think we um
should be divided by n so then you
should really normalize earlier
questions so one thing I don't
understand like when you say typically
it's divided by n i see that a lot but I
don't know that's up to me here because
I'm just working with the actual
accounts you know and so I agree that
this approximation whether it's good or
not it depends on the relative number of
events in that time interval and so I I
don't know what it would mean to divide
s by n here
um well because each in each in the each
infectious in
I mean Encounters in other individuals
at a certain rate which is given by Beta
and then that encounter will produce an
infection if the encountered individual
is susceptible which is uh which happens
with probability s of T divided by n
because
I mean then you can have another
parameter but yeah I mean the
interpretation of beta would of course
change I'm not sure
so I'm not sure about the normalization
with n but I certainly think regardless
you you might be right it might be more
natural to have has to be the constant
part and I should think about that yes
that's a great idea thank you
foreign
excellent presentation just some
fantastic work
here I'll follow up on the same So
epidemiologically speaking what it means
uh when you divide by n so this one is
mass action instance which essentially
means your uh your your contact rate
actually scales the total population if
you look at the formulation of epidemic
model but if you divide by n it's a
standard incidence it means basically a
constant contact rate is console
regardless where you are so if you are
someone in the I class you know so
you're transmitting at the right beta
but you're transmitting only to the
proportion of the population that are
currently susceptible
so that's why you have S of T divided by
node yeah that's that's the idea so so
it's a distinction between mass action
incidence and the standard incidence
yeah so Mass actually means basically
your contact rate is scaling was total
population is so proportional you're
right that might actually do better when
when you have more events yeah
interesting thank you thank you both
well
not to contradict the experts here but
to me it seems it really depends on the
stage of the infection so if I'm in the
beginning the eye is very small
it makes sense to keep s constant over
some time period and say it effectively
doesn't change much and I goes from one
to five to twenty that's a branching
process
but once you get into the time where he
sort of has a lot of infected
you could probably do either
it's my guess and one can probably in
that range you could also do what
corrected that you are just replace one
of them by the inter and you can do
whatever you want as long as you fix
your decision before running the mcmc
because otherwise you're in the Adaptive
territory and it's hard to preserve
stationarity I I will say yeah so we're
whichever one we choose we're only
approximating that contribution to the
overall infection rate right so both s
and I are changing in that interval and
that's important because I think a lot
of models just say s is constant but
that's not the case here s is changing
but the rate is changing has one part
that shouldn't be constant at least
yeah
that makes sense
the question as well but maybe it's
because it went a bit fast so when you
know exactly the time at which people
are infected so I agree with you that
you have a natural proposal law but then
you say
um at some point you don't know anymore
whether the people are infected or not
and for me this
um this increases a lot the dimension of
of the unexplored space and and I and
you have a like um facts that tells you
that your proposal is good on yeah so
this is a great question so first of all
in the network case you're right we
assume we need the infections and then I
moved to the case where we don't for
this I don't know how to do this and the
network case yet but as far as whether
the proposals are good we can we mostly
empirically verified that this process
is close and of course we can we can do
studies on it agrees as the time
interval gets small so that that's an
easy thing to prove okay and this is in
fact you don't know how to do it on
networks we don't know how to do that on
networks no yeah I don't yeah
is there other question are there other
questions
so all right so let's thank the speaker
again thank you